buonasera buonasera io sono andrea
delogu sono una ragazza di 30 anni da
quattro anni più o meno e questa cosa si
potra si protrarrà per altri 4 5 anni
così ad occhio e la mia storia
raccontata in un libro dal titolo la
collina edito fandango lavoro tutti i
giorni sono vado in diretta in radio su
radio 2 con un programma che conduco con
altri due pazzi
dopo di che faccio parte del processo
del lunedì poi conduco troppo giusti un
programma di cinema ovviamente di marco
giusti e tutto questo per me è
bellissimo
per alcuni di voi giustamente molto
frivolo
però per me è bellissimo contando che
fino ai 18 19 anni veniva un attacco
d'ansia di fronte a un testo scritto e
che non riuscivo neanche troppo a
parlare bene quindi tutto questo per me
è la realizzazione di un sogno
la comunicazione a 360 gradi per fare
tutto questo diciamo così ho attinto a
un segreto un segreto che io oggi voglio
condividere con voi
ci tengo davvero tanto e il segreto è
questo questo il mio segreto è un
segreto molto particolare o qualcosa di
diverso qualcosa che forse a scusate non
avete non avete capito non avete letto
c'è problema
questo il mio segreto non si capisce
però allora forse così è meglio ho
imparato di più dalla gente in rete sui
social e a scuola perché sono dislessica
era difficile prima vero un po
frustrante quando qualcuno deve leggere
velocità o quando qualcuno deve leggere
voi non capite
ecco pensate che una persona dislessica
tipo come me con questa sensazione
civile tutta la vita io per tutta la
vita mi sono sentita un po stupida
cioè realtà non è ancora finita la mia
vita quindi anzi però insomma per molti
anni mi sono sentita un po stupida io vi
ho odiato a ognuno di voi anche a voi
che ci state guardando da casa su
periscope io vi ho odiato il
profondamente perché e voi sapevate le
tabelline voi riuscivate a declinare
ogni verbo voi sapevate leggere in
classe e dell'incredibile e io vivo
diamo adesso ho smesso di odiar v però
prima vediamo tantissimo lo diamo anche
le mie professoresse però poi ho capito
che non era colpa poi nessuno è come la
colpa vostra colpa delle professoresse
anche se
un giorno alle medie se mi ricordo bene
ho perso il primo posto per un concorso
regionale di temi per i troppi errori
quindi mi fece arrivare seconda mi
convocò la mia professoressa e mi disse
che si era vergognata tantissimo nel
dover ammettere che era stata la mia
professoressa di italiano
questa cosa mi sconvolse perché anche se
non ero ancora al corrente di essere
dislessica pensavo ok ma mi scusi ma il
tema andava bene quindi tema lo avevo
creato io
il problema erano gli errori però gli
errori che ho fatti perché lei non è
stato in grado di insegnarmi che errori
non fare quindi il problema non era il
mio avrei dovuto rispondere
semplicemente ma come si permette
professoressa l'errore suo non mio
per quale motivo mi sta giudicando ma
non lo feci perché come ho detto
poc'anzi avevo dei problemi nel parlare
infatti anni dopo e spesi 50 euro l'ora
per molti mesi per risolvere questo
piccolo problema della r che adesso mi
vanto molto le dire ramazza correre rosa
ora 50 euro spesi molto bene grazie
questo era molto importante ricordarlo
perché poi i soldi erano anche dei miei
genitori ho cercato di allinearmi un po
agli standard quindi ho cercato di
ridimensionare un po tutti i miei sogni
e questa cosa non è bella perché un
bambino dovrebbe sognare sempre in
grande dovrebbe sempre cercare di voler
il massimo di fare l'astronauta di fare
l'attore famoso o che ne so di scrivere
le canzoni migliori quelli devono essere
i sogni poi ci penserà la vita dirti che
non ce la puoi fare
ma un bambino non può smettere di
sognare eppure io ero costretto a farlo
perché non riuscivo perché già vedevo in
classe che arrivavo dopo gli altri e
questa cosa fa male poi arrivarono
insomma le prime i primi test dove si
vedeva che aveva un problema di
apprendimento e allora mi dicevano ma
dai andrea non ti preoccupare un sacco
di persone famose hanno avuto problemi
di apprendimento un sacco di persone
famose tipo queste non riuscivano a
leggere bene come te tipo leonardo da
vinci einstein vedono ed amici scusate
ma questa cosa in tempura più ansia ma
che vi aspettate da me c'è un attimo
io non voglio farmi genio non voglio
salva il mondo non voglio vincere dei
premi oscar nobel liu e ora è soltanto
una verdi realtà che vengono avanti a un
foglio scritto era semplice quindi mi
dispiace anche per loro magari se ne
stanno accorgendo adesso ma non mi hanno
aiutato per niente
poi arrivò la soluzione che non furono i
corsi di recupero perché quei limiti
faceva fare tutti ma semplicemente era
un allungare il mio problema perché le
ore di scuola erano un grossissimo
problema per me mi sentivo davvero
diversa è davvero stupida e poi ci
mandavano al pomeriggio era un inferno
la mia vita non so se riuscite a un
attimo a pensarlo quasi 24 ore su 24
perché poi tornati a casa ed univoche di
altri genitori che rendono avi combinato
niente ti sentivi inadatto la soluzione
arrivo dalla rete
all'improvviso io ho scoperto internet e
mi si aprì un mondo alcuni danno
scoperto con intorno al mondo io invece
no io l'ho scoperto scrivendo meglio per
me poi non voglio dedicarla attenzione
io ho cominciato a scrivere a scrivere
vabbè in chat a scrivere sui primi
social messenger che vabbè che considero
un social ads aver lanciato comune
myspace
quanti di voi avevano myspace all'inizio
poi dopo ci ha distrutto a meno che non
abbiate un gruppo che non ascolta
nessuno
perché solo chi non viene ascoltato o
myspace ha adesso però mai spesso non ci
vede più
io li ho cominciato a scrivere ho
cominciato a sapere che poteva avere del
tempo che nessuno mi stava guardando che
nessuno mi stava aspettando soprattutto
quindi non potevo scrivere
rileggere capire e inviare il cazzo
avevo sbagliato ancora però era online
diciamo che andrea non se ne accorge
nessuno invece no
arriva la gente che mi prendeva in giro
gente che insomma si prendeva gioco di
me
poi però c'erano anche persone che
semplicemente mi dicevano guarda ha
invertito queste lettere guarda questi
accenti sono sbagliati guarda manca una
parola e questa cosa mi chiede coraggio
perché piano piano
cominciai a scrivere sempre di più e mi
piaceva farlo mi piaceva raccontare di
me mi piaceva far sorridere alla gente e
lo leggevo dei commenti che mi
lasciavano e quindi poi ha aperto anche
un blog così tanto per dire cosa
impossibile se pensiamo a qualche anno
prima con tutti i piccoli problemi
esistenziali avevo e cominciando a
scrivere la cosa che ti piace di più le
prime volte è difficile spiegarlo perché
tutti voi sicuramente non avete provato
questa frustrazione non so se c'è
qualche dislessico qua però quando
cominci a scrivere comincia a prenderti
il tuo tempo
senti che lo puoi fare sente che c'è
qualcuno che ti sta ascoltando santi
qualcuno che non ti sta giudicando poi
ci sono quelli che ti giudicano che ti
prendono in giro che ti attaccano ma
quello fa lo stesso quello tanto ci sono
sempre io non mi sentivo colpita dentro
mi sentivo ferita anche perché in rete
per un po di tempo sono stata questa
io per molto tempo mi sono presentata
questa faccia
e con il nome sopra questo è un esempio
che poi ovviamente mi sono rovinato al
facebook per 60 giorni per far vedere
questo esempio perché ho scoperto che se
cambi il nome su facebook tre 60 giorni
poi sei costretto a tenere quello quindi
io sarò anche no per due mesi per colpa
vostra grazie quindi con questo non
essendo me essendo un fake
ho trovato tutto il coraggio del mondo è
veramente mi sono impegnata veramente ho
fatto qualcosa ma non è finita qui
perché lì era semplicemente un trovare
coraggio nel comunicare poi è arrivato
il t9 lo so che sembra strano ma il t9
di ascoltato perché avevo la possibilità
di dare la colpa a qualcuno perché
quando scrivi tutti voi l'avete fatto
almeno una volta nella vita lo sappiamo
scusa samanda il team 9 guarda l'ho
appena installato non è vero avevate
sbagliato e io questa cosa l'ho usata
tantissime volte però mi sentivo meno in
colpa mi sentivo meno distratta anche
perché poi ti nome ti cambia cavolo una
frase cioè non è che non è che da una
logica quindi questa cosa può veramente
mi giustificava ad essere dislessiche
anche perché noi dislessici invertiamo
le fasi per camere lettere quindi non
può trovare una logica in quella parola
magari che cerca una qualsiasi e quella
qualsiasi è sempre sbagliata quindi
continua che ho preso un po di tempo ma
dopo il t9
la vera svolta per me è stato lo smart
phone lo smartphone è aperto il mondo
perché lo smartphone ma reso felice
perché
perché mi segnava con il russo l'errore
non mi cambiava la parola lui mi segnava
con il rosso l'errore quindi immaginate
tu scrivi qualcosa e qualcuno ti cambia
le parole quindi non hai tempo di
imparare però poi dare la colpa a
qualcuno invece tu scrivi qualcosa prima
di inviare e controlli e vedi le strisce
rosse sotto quindi torni su quella
parola a leggi respiri conti e cerchi di
capire campo ma la vuoi cambiare e la
puoi sbagliare un milione di volte
veramente la puoi sbagliare in
continuazione e questa cosa fa la
differenza perché non c'è nessuno che si
annoia perché un problema mio poi non so
se posso sapere l'ansa che mi saliva era
che non capivo e sapevo che quello
davanti a me che mi stava spiegando che
mi stava cercando di far leggere che mi
stava aspettando si stava annoiando
terribile e infatti anche per quello che
ho parlato molto veloce per un lungo
periodo della mia vita che sono mi
capiva e adesso arrivare a fare qualche
pausa per darvi la possibilità di capire
meglio quello che dico ok abbiamo
parlato dello smartphone e lo smartphone
mi ha aiutato anche a capire delle
regole semplicissime che tipo questa voi
lo sapete ovviamente io l'ho scoperta 45
anni fa quando ho cominciato a leggere
qualsiasi cosa vi capitasse per le mani
addirittura prendevo i treni roma milano
il ragazzo purtroppo cosa è giusto per
rimanere da sola e poter leggere avere
delle scuse ho speso i soldi inutilmente
però ho scoperto grazie ai social grazie
allo smartphone che il primo perché è
sbagliato perché perché
e non va bene il secondo invece giusto
ora io non voglio chiedere non ne sta a
voi
chi lo sapeva alzi la mano chi lo
sapevano aumentino
non fate che adesso alzi la mano
meno della metà vi ho insegnato qualcosa
scusate vabbè modo a concludere perché
non voglio tediarvi oltre anche perché
sto parlando italiano quindi vedo che
pare tutti benissimo l'inglese non
vorrei annoiarvi e molto urgente e
fondamentale anzi direi che si riesca a
capire se un bambino è affetto da
dislessia semplicemente se un bambino un
problema subito non bisogna aspettare
righe 18 19 ma anche soltanto che a
rimini 10 15 subito appena inizia le
scuole ci sono interesse si può fare
qualcosa si può cercare di aiutarli
davvero aiutarmi tempo è passato per me
però io sarei stata molto felice e
sarebbe utile e tutti i professori e
maestre anzi imparassero due modi di
insegnare perché un modo funzione va
bene ma l'altro no
in italia noi dislessici siamo 5 per
cento
sono un po quel 5 per cento potete modo
giovani sono tantissimi il 5 per cento
non sono pochi sono davvero tanti quindi
perché una persona non può imparare anzi
purtroppo perdere le occasioni io sono
stata testarda avuto dei genitori che mi
hanno aiutato ma potevo perdere delle
occasioni potevo non essere felice come
si dice adesso quindi per quale motivo
non si inizia dall inizio
e poi c'è un'altra cosa e anche per il
motivo per cui sono qua ci tenevo essere
qua che è importantissimo che i
professori maestre ma che soprattutto i
genitori imparino ad usare la rete è
davvero importante perché la rete a me
mi ha salvato la vita ma reso una
persona contenta una persona felice una
persona combattiva perché mi sono data
il tempo io imparando a studiare da sola
imparando a cercare quello che mi
interessava prendendo il mio tempo lo so
io da sola però se qualcuno me lo poteva
spiegare un po prima non perdevo tutto
questo tempo non mi sentivo così male
per così tanti anni la rete ci ha mica
la rete ci può dare tantissimo ad
esempio gli audiolibri a me davvero
manufatto recuperare tanto di quel tempo
che non lo sa neanche raccontare perché
io tutti i libri che ci hanno dato alle
medie purtroppo gli avevo persi non ce
la facevo e poi un'altra domanda
vi siete mai chiesti per quale motivo le
reti ci sono così tanti siti dove porre
delle domande in modo anonimo ad esempio
qual è sinonimo di sinonimo questa è una
domanda hicks come anche sorriso se
niente si incolla al testo come hanno
fatto ad incollarlo nelle padelle
domanda legittima che nessuno la
risposta quindi se non fatto quelli che
sanno perché non è vero perché
abbreviazione una parola così lunga che
se no perché separato si scrive tutti
insieme mentre tutto insieme si scrive
si è parlato state ridendo non avreste
risposto vero non avreste perso 5 6
minuti per dare una risposta a queste
persone che magari davvero lo volevano
sapere però la rete dal fatto noi no
però la rete l'ha fatto e la rete siamo
noi però noi no ma la rete si quindi la
rete è più paziente di noi impariamo a
usarla grazie